whoo the famouser cam be careful with
the with the I'm ready okay what's going
on everybody for first week beef I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot one
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by Vince staples a second studio album
the much buzz about critically acclaimed
big fish theory is available now stream
it download it buy it but first the
wings of death Vince welcome to the show
how you feeling man I'm pretty good man
how about you I'm doing I've been
talking a lot of [ __ ] you have you came
in here pretty chirpy but I respected I
appreciate it you know I mean this is
this is booboo right now it's not it's
not done it's got a cheetah on it like
that's not hard body oh man how are you
a thought for your spice guy I'm from
the ghetto the other minion spicy us all
we got
[Music]
oh no I mean one thing this is our
playing games because I even play NASA
leaning on me we came branded so you
know got something you want so yeah it
takes up I'll take them off
I'll just go I'll just you know what
I'll just s'matter the the the board I
don't have a saucer just barbecue sauce
I love it already
I love it already it's kind of a fire
wing is right there's a very good they
don't have a lot of crunch torn but they
don't need that because the way the
chicken is cooked through and the
quality of the skin uh-huh no I mean so
I mean it was kind of biracial is a good
look darker here I feel you so I'll get
to music in a second but I want to start
on the gridiron because I know that
you're one of them are notable alumnus
of the Snoop Dogg Youth Football League
it was nice
we played the Carson Coast every days to
cheat oh they have a rivalry they had
grown ass men on the team then and the
Mission Viejo Cowboys used to cheat so I
just want everybody to know anthem kids
cheaters and I hope they never
prosecuted lies because they took a lot
for me as a kid but you know snow really
did it B we our names on our jerseys
that's the best clay it's the best time
she'll still dog really love football so
that's what they were without one
they went for the slight spice no need
the hint of flavor with a slight spice
that way it's like you go a little bit
hard it's like that's like for vegetable
now I mean maybe nice enchilada that's
what that's for
just like fire chicken there's like
braised chicken with hot sauce on it
it's rare that we have guests that like
the wings so when these are cooling on
me I'm found a sword at the suicide
wings you got to sign a waiver right I
mean I doesn't have a poem
I wonder how and raise and it's that
same thing we have to sign a waiver to
go for that back room extra hot because
they don't want to be liable if you just
drop dead or spontaneously combust if
you die off with a wings use a [ __ ]
so much more words about if you have a
heart attack off the wing should have
been vegan what if you throw up today
now I'm gonna eat
[Music]
you know when talking to you I think
that you have sort of a healthy distrust
of the industry and then for a 23 year
old you see more or less immune to the
trappings of Fame what are the mistakes
that you see young artists you make when
they experience overnight success
I'm guseong I come to Sochi like this I
go to the show and then I go home
save your money pay your tax is not
going to do this is bar if you like the
sauce this is good there isn't even like
some jerk chicken jerk chicken piece and
cause for peace occasion something like
that this is hot so like many of our
viewers you haven't grown out of your
gaming stage I came from kind of fallen
off bad in this over the ear headset age
sometimes gaming can be a more hostile
environment and you know hip-hop even oh
they saying here so much you know this
for any of that like I know what I look
like
well your little fat [ __ ] outside his
kid plays UK here by like 15 I'll be but
I play all games getting me funny
I'm kid that picking robobone mama call
timeouts I went to the whole clock I get
y'all ready I'm coming back
stop running pika Rose you're such a
Gensler all right we don't use them
words around your boom but on the noon
to K if you say stuff like that you get
a technical so I'm at the line you put
me boil them at the bottom of the line
just your mom's a [ __ ] just cancel the
[ __ ] I'm like but what about me bro like
we talk we playing me ain't gonna bring
my mom into this [ __ ] safe to say I'm
real good like I'm real good of all the
rappers that you've played with over the
years who's the best gamer is that logic
people say it's logic it's probably
logic but he be running from me he
called me on Cory for another day on
FaceTime like we'd set min I mean we're
going to play like so you have a switch
no Dan what a little damage hit up your
PlayStation are you running bro taco
thought it was hard whooped on him
Donnell Genesis whooped on him how they
create everybody else to get out they
play Mario Kart I teach I'm playing
grown man again if you can't win a
championship or kill nobody in the game
you stifle me bro
[Music]
okay okay you're into it yeah I'm proud
of you but then the first time I had
this but I didn't have it on my wings
like this mouthing dancing oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah you've gone to a couple
bottles
yeah and I'm too big so anyone who
listens to your music knows that your
rep Long Beach to the fullest so what
I've done is I've gone to TripAdvisor
and I've pulled some of the best things
to do in the LBC so what I want to do is
bounce them off of you and you can tell
me if it's just some lame tourist trap
if you'd recommend it to a friend if you
know somewhere off the beaten path
that's better does that sound good
that's good all right the Queen Mary no
you're gonna shout oh you might see a
lot of drunk old people but shipwreck at
the Queen Mary
you little Halloween blah blah you're
getting Syrian popped off it's a trap on
a sinking ship best place to visit in
downtown Long Beach so go to birth 55
they catching it figure out our music on
Pete Rose fire you pay like three
dollars you get you a hole and salmon
with fries with coleslaw with all the
fixings they cut the tops of teal tied
down there on the counter because you
know [ __ ] still that's how you know
really it they maybe they were doing it
they put a crab off the tank smack
cousin Terry out of there boom could get
us delicious best seafood you'll ever
have your life if you ever been on one
of those whale watching or dolphin
cruises 100% worth it
we'll watch this low-key sad though you
feel like you in vain a personal space
because they look at you they gonna go
up and I'm gonna focus you in slew them
of it I feel like if he would have got
pissed off he would have been out of
here it would have been curtains for
everybody yeah but little washington's
fine if you ever been to that Knott's
Berry Farm and when a part here worth it
are not worth it it depends on when you
go okay I get shot there to a couple
places we lose in high school you can
like not scary farm you go on like a
Saturday night
in be ready but I love Knott's Berry
Farm my favorite thing part they got
crazy good preserves and biscuits and
stuff on me like your grandmama house
with roller coasters when I say Bradley
no what's the first thing that comes to
mind along proudly they did love the
city
they flight was like in a for fryer to
Scott [ __ ] on me I'm not [ __ ]
with that right now because he said
don't keep doing a group when I die and
guess what his nicotine kept the group
going while he died she's not cool
[Applause]
alright so this one dirty dicks very
aggressive Brandon this is fires hole
are you Justine is just good like I knew
you'd like this one
mmm mr. rightness just don't do Yelp
reviews I'm an evil despot up right I
was having fun too
they only seen one but I had like a year
and a half of Yelp reviews I was going
hard because you did a hot chicken
review everybody wrote about is flavor
homie um it was like a lying down block
like foot eventually that's why I knew I
was I was low-key going somewhere not
because my children and when I can make
a [ __ ] wait line for some chicken s
content enormous did you ever have to
write a one-star review because the one
that got all the press was a five-star
would you ever have to write a one-star
I'm only going 5-star places I like that
I like that because I feel like there's
some people who only do one star reviews
like they only have a yard thing to be
at all so it's like oh man the food is
delicious but I asked for water not only
got two ice cubes the one stars yeah
right I know if I'm going to somewhere
grimy I want to grind the experience you
know I mean I'm not looking for
everything to be no Nobu and you go to
wipe off snaky pre pouring your water
you gonna feel uncomfortable bro I don't
feel like they trying to hang me in the
back
I'm not written into that bro while they
go through what you want we don't got
that that's it alright oh five stars you
know I mean you have to contextualise a
restaurant come on bro a [ __ ] movie not
supposed to have good lighting bro
Vanessa firing our Micah see it's hot
right but it's not like that it got that
bitter high mm-hmm what's in this and
it's just nasty just nasty like this
Chipotle qualifiers Mexican food near no
Chipotle is gentrification and then
killing people this deep-dish Pizza
Pizza we went to some place in Chicago
it look like old-school Mafia like Thai
restaurant it was really poorly lived
like old people in their children
smoking cigarettes in the front I'm
feeling real like so like Chicago right
it happened open for a really long time
I guess was I won the first place is
that deep-dish are like they just gave
you a fold and then they like poured all
the ingredients in the boat and they put
the bread around the boat and they baked
the whole bowl and I was like this [ __ ]
looks disgusting it's the best pizza
I've ever had in my life
so I'm rockin Chicago off that along
what in your opinion is the best food
city in the country do you have one
Boston easy bossy easy
Simon close Boston you can get chowder
the seafood they got good burgers they
have the most elite selection of fast
food change and they got the squiding
constant and we've seen a fight for gay
rights in Boston really yeah they chased
and do down the street blah blah blah
them for no reason they said slur he
said we think his I'm crazy I'm gonna
say on camera he says I'm crazy the gay
dude did boom well then they get out the
quality's gonna jump up his brother come
out the stores where guys are exactly
like he had a six-pack of beer in us and
he spiked it boom
sip your shirt off what do you wanna do
so the [ __ ] what if he's gay I'm like
this is crazy and core light now we were
gonna wash it the polling standing
directly mixed us a cup of this [ __ ] is
crazy right and just keep watching it
I'm like that Boston for you bro run
y'all fade and we're gonna talk about it
later if anybody can stab somebody go to
jail other than that we out of here in
the middle of delicious and right across
the street it was a life for ice cream
now she was a life like what was like
doughnuts or something everybody eaten
bro why did the crime rate so high out
there because everybody is all calorie
DUP and just my man at all eats in fear
home bro I love Boston man shout out
their time is very shallow gently round
our this is just disgusting
that's nasty right away it's like don't
make you try I got soap on behind if
it's not dry as she has House lost yeah
it's just nasty bout the Hidden Valley
can't save you she just like poison she
be ashamed y'all [ __ ] yourself
or chills it's someone who leaves a
straightedge lifestyle which is more
annoying to be around being sober around
a bunch of drunk people or sober around
a bunch of super high people strong how
people relax take that out of this test
crash the bomb again because they like
no I don't care of you you ain't gonna
like it he fix it but [ __ ] gonna hurt
your face I can be careful with the with
the I'm ready
Napoli I don't want you to hit oh okay
there is move you've been here before
what do people not know about the
pitfalls of being a rapper ESMA a small
leadership Charles it's hard to run
around it's hard to breathe you gotta
breathe constantly right if you can't
breathe became deal job I say a cure
sauce for my show please almost I said
you's a [ __ ] [ __ ] wait for killin your
show pitch you want grateful all right
Oh
music land up here with that are you
ready to move on to Megadeth sauce just
not coming it yeah and for death sauce
we have a special guest all right so we
welcome to the table Cory Smith for the
people who don't know Cory Cory is
Vince's manager but so much more a
mentor a brother young guy who is going
to support his man through glares
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage and let
the record show Cory's has been doing
these wings over there in the courts
going right along with show business
partnership that's for real I just want
to say something real quick and it's
coming for Vincent staples and no other
party stop hitting the homie up access
for tickets to Dave Chappelle the radius
is it Superman yeah Questlove answer
question hey Cory I need I got you your
Questlove
Brando [ __ ] legs folks one five
years pop up like a weed glance you had
a baby Dean we're not gonna leave this
out and fire by the way we need a
feature or it what's up what they show
I think Oh sandwich oh mama you happy
see this is why I'm you okay so this
wing I mean ha is Blair's Megadeth sauce
with liquid rage Blair is a man's I'm
your Jersey
[Music]
[Applause]
just [ __ ] up y'all
till digestion my children it is none
when he hit the yacht I mean is he are
you not saying it's about a big better
thing I mean I'm good with this yeah
he's a gig so Cory I'm happy that I have
you here because I'm happy that you're
distracted by the death sauce so I can
get some truth out of you okay what's
the biggest pain-in-the-ass thing about
managing Vince staples a pain in the ass
mm-hmm just to be nonchalant about
everything but that's kind of like me so
what's the last thing you two argued
about we don't really argue not be like
I say like I wouldn't argue it anymore
really for the movie have a car if you
argue consensus yes it there have a
conversation conversation about a lot of
stuff we talk about press a lot all
right that's a good segue whose idea was
it to do this show all right are you
today a lot of it is the fact I think
people want and to say things that are
like you know you're not all up on the
book and don't even know the flavor is
the 9-pin pop [ __ ] will soak things they
take the story they put it in a box and
becomes that box and then it's like a
game of telephone between all the
different blogs that are running it and
then that gets out and then the
narrative is already cemented into a
place and then and every single
interview you do for like next three
years it's a promise I have to interview
sir
this one level please the first two
interviews I've had in months where they
didn't reference another interview yeah
every interview is about I'm spreading
the interview that I could have all we
hear just read out
[Music]
oh look at the homie chopper to America
tit ooh
hey bro there's gonna be fire you ready
all right so before you take a bite this
is the last step it is the hottest sauce
that we have and it's called the last
dab because it's tradition around here
and put a little dab on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
but you did make it this far
won't need a little chopping down there
we go stir dad you're right
[Music]
got you that's your right hold on
we're chilled haces mm-hmm agent booth
thank you
let's go say your granny and go buy this
for your mama okay we need both of them
okay
[ __ ] try me
thank you guys I appreciate them and you
too you too it's not about the whole
team winning whole team was about you
right now so I'm saying man it's hot but
it's not hot to the point that you don't
enjoy it bro and the lustre as a
consistency like texture to it so it's
not too runny not so we don't you can't
run from it is there any captures you
you haven't been captured Vince you're
very much operating above the hot sauces
right now you're very much in the cloud
this will are cleaning up because it is
nasty I feel it's it's heartening well
wear something I'll do this and I feel
me walking out here I'm looking chipper
so you've been labeled a nihilist a bit
of a curmudgeon and if I'm being real
that's probably what I find most
relatable about them staple what I do
care about your happiness and worry
about it a little bit if money were no
object how would you live out the rest
of your life I'm happy [ __ ] bro
you'd be surprised I mean Chairman's
fathers laughing okay it's not that but
and then it's passing bro I'm just off
the [ __ ] they got this thing where
everybody seen here a lot of each other
in a face we ain't in said stuff for
nobody couldn t do it that's a beautiful
feeling my mama don't work no more
lonely she be causing I ain't turn on
this channel five right now they needed
on Maury trippin that's my life life is
good and you know what else been staples
you came in you cleared the board you
conquered the wings you got on top of
the hot sauces it was an amazing
performance know who I'm looking at you
know me you know how to get down every
time I come to conflict you move when
she's going on a real song this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on to your life
big big theory in stores right now go
buy a spark camp with my name on it
that's for my mama we get big checks
over here we give them all back to the
kids
big fish during stores right now I'm
ascared parking wasn't paying attention
you want to know why we not like your
[ __ ] because we don't like you [ __ ]
so we don't want no features you can't
get nothing from us
don't want Shelby we don't look at that
you're some tribes who blacktron [ __ ]
not to know when the over the nose trash
Disney however I can reboot that fo you
[Music]
hello hot ones band Sean oven new outro
same message if you like what you saw
throw us a bone maybe please it is
dog-eat-dog here on the YouTube streets
hit that subscribe button
knowing that you subscribed it is
seriously the only thing that gets me
out of bed in the morning thank you very
much hot ones fans I love you